morning it's nice to see all of you here
my name is alder Kellerman and I'm a PhD
student at the School of Forestry and
environmental studies and in the
Department of Anthropology here at Yale
many of you have received emails from me
over the last few months and it's great
to see you all here today so I think
without further ado we'll get started
with our first panel of the morning this
town was on domestication titled porcine
prehistory and our three speakers this
morning are dr. Benjamin Arbuckle who is
an assistant professor of anthropology
at the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill where he directs the central
an Italian pastoralism product project
our second speaker will be Gregor Larsen
the director of ilio genomics and the
bio archeology research network in the
school of archaeology at the University
of Oxford and finally with hear from dr.
Philip Piper who is an associate
professor in archaeology at the
Australian National University of
Canberra
yes research focuses on human animal
interactions throughout prehistory in
Southeast Asia and since this is a topic
about which many of us may not have as
deep expertise as we have about other
topics I really wanted to encourage
people to ask basic foundational
questions after their talks so please
join me in welcoming our three speakers
and good morning everyone
I we're gonna do a quick bait-and-switch
on you actually I am not more than six
feet tall and very handsome and
good-looking that has been so he's gonna
be going second actually I'm gonna go
first and that'll be Ben and then it'll
be Phil we decided to do that because
the way that we had discussed it on
email was that I would provide more of a
kind of a theoretical or larger scale
non regionally specific discussion of
kind of the basics of domestication
before Ben and Phil got into some more
of the regional aspects of pigs in
Southeast Asia and Southwest Asia so I
my understanding having read the project
or the program was that the final
session of this conference has to do
with human Pig intimacy and I may have
taken that
- literally and decided entirely
possible and decided instead to start
off in keeping with that theme with
discussion about pornography which on a
Saturday morning is maybe not the best
idea but I there is some there's some
relevance to to domestication and first
of all there's this really famous case
when I say really famous enemies most
people don't really know it I certainly
didn't know for a long time
Jaco Bella's versus Ohio in 1964 and
real Supreme Court case in which the
Supreme Court justices were asked to
adjudicate on a charge of obscenity
there was a proprietor of a theater in
Ohio who had been showing a film that
was racy to say the least and there was
a lawsuit brought against him to say
that he was violating the statutes which
claimed that he was not allowed to show
up scene films and so the Supreme Court
then had to watch the film in question
and decide whether or not this actually
constituted hardcore pornography which
I'm sure they were it was not the normal
thing that they usually do and they were
probably enjoying some aspect of that
but so Justice Stewart then has this
very famous phrase and it came up and
this applies to just about everything to
do with the continuum where he says and
trying to define what may be indefinable
this is the obscenity laws obscenity
laws are constitutional limited to
hardcore pornography I shall not today
attempt to define pornography and
perhaps I could never succeed in doing
so but I know it when I see it and this
film is not so this was not racy enough
in the Supreme Court justices to
persecute this gentleman for having
shown this film because it wasn't
hardcore pornography it was might be
softer corpora but where is the line
between hardware and software
pornography how are you asking and I
think that's a very good question
because when we ask that same question
we do the same thing in domestication
where we have a field for domestication
we know what wild ancestors look like we
know what domesticated animals look like
and therefore we know it when we see it
but trying to figure out what the
difference is between them where along
that continuum does a wolf become a dog
is a much more difficult question and
one that Justice Stewart rightly said
one that could be you could probably
never succeed in doing so in defining it
which is why I tend to shy away from
definitions of domestication in the
first place but so we know when we see a
dog we know when we see a domesticated
pig it looks nothing like a wild boar at
least in many aspects of it and we know
of course we the difference between the
two of them and we know that that is not
a wild red junglefowl we know that is
not
our jungle family no that is not a
render award while ago jungle foul and
in all three cases you would be
hard-pressed to guess that those animals
were even descended from wild red jungle
fowl
but domestication has clearly affected
the behavior and phenotype of these
animals to such a degree that there is
enough difference between them that
recognizing them as different things is
really quite simple the question then is
where do we draw that line and do we
even draw that line we could draw that
line there to save those on the spectrum
of the difference between wild and
domestic that line exists there or
perhaps for somebody else wouldn't spill
several thousand words in a very
high-profile journal to explain no no no
actually the line is drawn there and
what they're all trying to do is
dichotomize what is effectively a
continuum that exists within an
evolutionary framework so the other
thing that people tend to do is they use
this word domestication event there's a
paper coming out in PNAS on Monday which
uses this exact phrase by a colleague of
mine who frankly should know better and
the reason that I don't like
domestication event is because it does
three separate things it implies a
significant degree of human
intentionality in the process of
domestication it makes it sound like
domestication is a technological thing
not of biological things we're talking
about the inventing of lightbulbs or
inventing them class or in collecting of
pottery and those sorts of things and
that it can be invented that can be
invented full-stop by smart
goal-oriented people you can be sitting
on the open Russian plane and the Late
Pleistocene and spy a population of
wolves hunting some caribou and say you
know what I bet if we go grab one of
those puppies we can bring it back to
camp and maybe we can make it have an
upturn tails and floppy ears and hang
out with our three-year-old it's just
this is not happening this is not how
domestication works and this level of
intentionality though certainly an
aspect of much further portions of the
domestication spectrum at least very
early on is not what this is all about
and I believe that both Ben and Phil are
going to speak to this as well so
Mindy's Eder published a paper about
three years ago now which really I think
helped to define or help to structure
the way that we think about
domestication and what she said was that
you can get two domestic animal through
at least three separate mutually
exclusive pathways wherein each animal
starts off as a wild animal and finishes
as a domestic animal the way they get
there is very different so first she
defines this thing called anthropoid
or so the commensal pathway which starts
with apps or anthropology animals are
being a
did to a human niche and in this case
this dogs and cats and rats and mice and
pigeons all these sorts of things are
more or less attracted to the kinds of
resources that we are providing on the
environment and they're coming to us
initially before we're going after them
then there's the prey pathway where you
have animals that we are actively
hunting and so you start with prey and
move to game management than herd
management before you get to captive
animal control and intensive breeding
again I would argue that this itself is
a more of a slippery slope with process
involving a series of labor traps where
people even when you start hunting goats
and sheep and cows that you are not
actually intending ever to domesticate
them you were just trying to manage a
wild resource and then there is the
directed pathway where you just skip
straight from the wild ancestor into
captive animal control and breeding cows
lack of a prey pathway and then you got
hamsters is the last one
hamsters are quite interesting my
grandmother was born in 1913 she's still
alive and when she was born there were
no hamsters and it's kind of interesting
to think that there are people like who
were born into a hamster free world when
there are millions of hamsters now
occupying bedrooms of four-year-olds all
over the US and elsewhere and hamsters
were domesticated I put that in quotes
because they were simply grabbed from
the deserts in Syria and brought into a
lab setting and those that were able to
survive in captivity then were under
selective pressure in the lab setting
and then his pets and everything else
and so but the reason that was possible
is because we already had a significant
we already knew what domestic animals
were and if they didn't survive that
process well then we wouldn't have
domestic animals but if they did then we
can go through this directed problem
projected process so last year at Dorian
Fuller and I did a quick review of the
archaeological literature and in every
single case regardless of where we
looked at in the initial part of the
world every first domestic animal that
we saw whether it was South America or
East Asia or any worlds they were the
commensal and so commensal and there was
always start your prey animals are later
and then finally you've got there
directed species we had to stop this
chart at 500 BC or 500 BP because the
number of animals that have followed the
directed pathway now so overwhelmed
those that followed either of the other
two pathways that that significantly
colors our perspective how domestication
happens in the first place but they can
only happen once you've got a domestic
animal in the initial process is very
different than subsequent ones so I
thought I would come back all the way
back to pigs I thought I would tell you
a story of how a paper that we published
ten years ago was really absolutely 100%
completely wrong when thinking about pig
domestication now initially people have
said that there were pigs were
domesticated first in the Near East and
also simultaneously in East Asia and we
what we did is we grabbed a whole bunch
of mitochondrial sequences from museum
specimens of wild boar across the
old-world distribution of pigs or wild
boar and what we found was that there
was a very tight correlation between the
geography of a region where the pigs was
found and its mitochondrial signature so
that it was reciprocally monophyletic in
such a way that if you told me where a
pig was from i could tell you what
genetic signature had and if you told me
what genetic signature I could tell you
with 99% confidence where this thing was
from which is a lovely thing to do and
then we thought hey wait if we can do
that then perhaps if we look at the
genetic signature of the domestic pigs
across the old world then if we find a
domestic Pig with a signature that
matches a local wild boar then that's
possibly or probably even an area where
pigs were domesticated so we did that
exact thing and we came up with seven
different locations where there were
local domestic pigs that match the
mitochondrial signature of the wild boar
and those spread across the old world
like that and we went hey this is
fantastic this overturns centuries of
Investigation about Pig domestication
and we got really arrogant and nasty and
we went full on scientific rock star
mode and we said the genetic evidence
here presented clear proof from multiple
centers of domestication across Eurasia
i am i was a young ignorant grad student
at the time and i'm still upset at my
advisors and at the editors of the
journal for being for using the word
proof which is just insane my students
would never do that now but we did
anyway we went one step further then we
said the our data show domestication was
not as rare as previously thought and
now the question now is not where were
pigs domesticated but rather where were
they not domesticated and we were
chuckling to ourselves we come up with
this very pithy very funny line for its
new scientists picked up the story and
it was all very vague and outlandish and
the reason we were it was big an
outlandish and we were very confident
he's precisely because it was 100% wrong
and we started figuring this out because
what we realized when we went back to
the ancient DNA and we started getting
signatures from archaeological material
going all the way back to six or seven
or eight thousand years ago this star
represents the single site
China where we were able to get a pig
signature in eastern Anatolia where
there is no question that pigs were
originally de más
the weather was pray pathway or
commensal pathway or something in
between is not yet determined but at
least it looked like the very first pigs
had this on a blue signature and then
when you get into western Turkey it
looks like they all have these yellow
signatures now there's no evidence for
an independent domestication process in
the same way that you have it in eastern
Turkey and these pigs then where
domestic ones have these yellow
signatures and we're like okay well
maybe this is an independent
domestication maybe is that when the
pigs get there they start acquiring the
mitochondrial signature of the local
wild war population so it becomes kind
of there's admixture with populations
it's very different than the actual
domestication and we should have guessed
this because we'd seen it before if you
use Pryor in a paper where and the
Neolithic when you have people first
moving into Europe the red circles in
this case of the wild boar and the
yellow ones are all a domestic pigs so
people are bringing in a pig from
Anatolia into Europe that is has a very
different mitochondrial signature than
the local wild boar and they're taking
it all the way to Paris a couple
thousand kilometers over a few thousand
years and then soon after 3900 BC they
still have domestic pigs but all those
domestic pigs are now red so suggesting
not an independent domestication process
in Europe but rather a kind of a
vacuuming sucking up of the local
genetic variation into your domestic
population so that those pigs are simply
mating with the local wild boar and then
you're getting the offspring from that
and then it overturns and then
completely eradicate the original
genetic signature that came in so
nothing to do with an independent
process and everything to do simply with
admixture and then we started thinking
well actually if you look around the
literature this is a lot more common
than people maybe have given credit for
we know that in pigs in the 19th century
there was the pig Improvement Program
where in Europe where people were
bringing in Asian pigs Asian domestic
pigs into European stock such that now
all European breeds have at least are
approximately 30% Asian DNA and they
were doing that for all kinds of reasons
involving the rate of growth the overall
size in some cases the number of piglets
and a whole very slew of other traits
that were very favorable to the people
who are breeding pigs at the time and we
start looking elsewhere and it's true of
a whole range of plants and animals so
in chickens we know the chickens are
primarily descended from the red jungle
fowl but those yellow legs that you see
are actually coming from the gray jungle
fowl or Galison arathi which is from
South Asia so this is not an independent
domestication of sonority and simply
that this other wild species contributed
some genes
into the domestic chickens that were
hanging out in South Asia as they were
moving through into Western Eurasia cows
well everything in Africa is some
combination of taurine and in de'cine
touring the cows that you're familiar
with into seeing the cows with the hump
on the back that you were more more
generally associated with South Asia but
you find a lot of them in Central
America and South America as well and
you get all kinds of hybrids so
everything's a certain percentage of
those hybrids of either touring or
interesting so this kind of general
process of blending and ubering up and
mixing different things is relatively
common horses of course maybe not a
surprise that this particular paper a
few years ago found that the spread of
horse domestication out of Western
Eurasia was characterized by high levels
of integration from local wild
populations you have your domestic horse
you move to an area where there's wild
horses and you mate with those wild
horses and acquire the genetic material
from those wild horses everywhere you go
across Western Eurasia and then you
start moving into the the plants and
it's exactly the same thing in fact
apples the people using different
terminology but they mean the same thing
in this case it's bi-directional gene
flow between domesticated Apple and the
European crabapple resulted in the
current M domestica being genetically
more closely related to this species
then to its central agent progenitor
which means of course it has exist
exactly like the pinks
apples domesticated outside of Europe
but when they get to Europe they start
hybridizing with the European apples and
then they end up looking more like
European than they did from their
original wild ancestors grapes exactly
the same story domesticated in the near
East moved into Europe start hybridizing
with the European in fact every single
plant down and we started looking at has
exactly the same pattern if you have a
domestic thing and you move it somewhere
where there is something capable of it
reproducing with it will reproduce with
that and then it'll become sort of a big
blended mix of all the genetics this one
is kind of fun this is the citrus family
I won't read through this entire thing
but it just gets insane I've really
never known the difference between
pomelos and tangerines and oranges and
whatever else we call them in regional
dialects and things but it's what you
end up with is this is ridiculous
whose paper which basically said
everything is a hybrid of everything
else and we're only because we have
access to the genome level now we can
start to figure out what's contributed
what to what and now there's possible
ghost progenitors and things that we
haven't sequence it's just a complete
absolute nightmare of a mess but it's a
whole lot of fun and kind of expect it
for something that was closely related
so we did some some work recently where
we showed can we look at this more
quantitatively can we think about
admixture as a process that's happening
while looking at the correlation between
the genetic signature and the geographic
signature so I did this about Easter and
you can tell because Eminem is usually
aren't this color but I went with the
more pastels because it kind of easier
to see and in this particular case if
you think of this as a geographic area
where you've got these four different
populations of column pigs and in those
are the color represents a genetic
signature and the region on the map
shows where they're from if you look at
the correlation between the genetic
distance and the geographic distance in
this case everything is nicely
segregated and so then you can do the
short ones are closely genetically
related and the further ones away
geographically are more genetically
related geographically separated as well
and so you've got an r-squared value
there of about one and then the same
thing happens when you if you start
mixing things you start moving them
around that landscape that r-squared
value starts to drop a little bit so
that's less than one and if everything
becomes complete blended math mix where
everything's just made in hybridized
with everything so everything is
absolutely everywhere then your R
squared R squared value is about zero
and everything is completely blended and
when we look at wild boar the first
number that we get for wild boar is 0.7
which is pretty close to one which is
really high and that you would expect
given what we showed you before about
how there is a very tight correlation
between the genetics and the geography
but when we look at domestic pigs it
drops all the way down to more than just
over zero point two which is just
ridiculously small so that really
suggests strongly that people are moving
their domestic things across the
landscape
hybridizing with the wild boar and with
other domestic pigs from other places
and you're getting a scenario where your
pigs are like your pastel M&Ms and
everything is just mixed up all over the
place it's a huge amount of admixture
same thing with wolves and dogs wolves
are reasonably high dogs are just about
as close to zero as possible because
we've been very much more effective at
moving dogs around than we have with
pigs there are wild animals where this
is happening as well in fact everything
that people are not doing with genomes
makes it sound like this admixture thing
is more the rule than the exception and
so you've got butterflies and people are
showing this with nice trees where
rather than a bifurcating tree becomes
more of a cloud where everything's
swapping genes around so in the
butterflies you can get really good
species that are swapping up to sixty
percent of the genetic material and
still retaining their integrity
morphologically and behaviorally
mosquitoes there's a swap and stuff left
right and center humans are swapping
stuff less right and center this is the
most recent picture from David Wright's
lab at Harvard showing that Denis Evans
Neanderthals modern humans everything
everywhere is just hot just shagging
perpetually and and swapping jeans like
you wouldn't believe so it's not just
our domestic animals we're not just
saying that they're the ones doing this
we're attitude so so once so I would say
the lesson of all of this is that we
really need to differentiate between two
distinct uses of the word domestication
this gets thrown around in a very
simplistic fashion I feel and really
what we need to do is say look there's
this first thing which means an
independent initial process of
domestication and that's fine I'm very
happy with the word for that purpose
because that's I think what we all mean
by that and then there's the second
thing which is subsequent admixture with
populations that were not involved in
the original domestication itself that
is not domestication however it is often
interpreted as such and that was the
mistake we made 10 years ago when we
looked at patterns of admixture assume
that was independent domestication and
thereby claim the pigs were domesticated
seven times which of course every
archaeologist when we said this were
like regular you're insane really no we
got genetics in there like you're insane
and now we're like yes okay weird saying
so subsequent admixture is not
domestication in fact durian Fleur eV
and I have come up with this phrase
inter breast of capture which yes
doesn't roll off the tongue very lightly
but it kind of gets the point which is
that what instead of domesticating
something you are simply capturing the
genetics of that wild population or that
other domestic patient when domestic
population when you move that new area
and I think also that the general under
appreciation of this phenomenon of this
admixture confuses definitions of
domestication and biases our
interpretation and I say this as having
done so 10 years ago making it very
difficult for us to come up with
accurate ways to infer the past from the
present and if you are insisting that
every time you see a new signature
somewhere that that is an independent
domestication process you are almost
certainly going to be wrong about that
because everything that we've ever seen
from wild animals to domestic plants and
domestic animals is the same thing and I
think that we underneath it all I think
we really do have an appreciation for
this and we like it because there was a
really interesting philosopher that you
may be familiar with Carl Spackler from
a film was about 30 years ago now I
think in Caddyshack and he has this
brilliant phrase which only occurred to
me years after the fact because I saw
this film probably every night in
college for four years and he says in
speaking about a particular grass that
he was in charge of on the bush Wood
Country Club he said the grass was a
hybrid and it's across
Kentucky bluegrass featherbed Ben's in
Northern California sensimilla so
getting to this whole point of like the
grass itself was robust and strong and
important because it was a hybrid rather
than being something that was less
admixed of course the amazing stuff
about this is that you can play 36 holes
on it in the afternoon take it home and
just get stoned to the bejesus built
that night so I think that we do
appreciate admixture in some
circumstances anyway and then if we
extend that to our general appreciation
of domestication we'll all be better off
thank you very much
so I think if there is one or two
pressing questions briefly I could take
that but otherwise we can move
relatively speedily on get to these
three guys and then we can all sit at
this this nice table and take some more
general questions so please wait until
you have the microphone to ask your
question so that it so that it comes out
nicely they're recording it I just have
a quick question um is the admixture
intentional or are the wild animals
coming to the domesticated animals or
the domesticated animals escaping yeah
that's a very good question I think it's
both I think there are certainly times
when it is intentional and there's some
really interesting data that Mindy cedar
has that from western anatolia we're on
a number of archaeological sites they
find an insane amount of neonates and it
almost one possible hypothesis that I
can throw out there is that it almost
looks like it and all likelihood you had
small populations of people and small
populations of pigs and in that case you
have to worry about inbreeding
depression and especially when you're
going into new areas where perhaps the
environment is not quite what it was
where the animals were originally
domesticated and it would actually prove
those animals to acquire the traits of
the local wild boar excuse me so what it
almost looks like is that there may have
been some relatively early degree of
intentionality of mating or grabbing
wild piglets bringing them to camp
mating them with your or and then
keeping those piglets that were still a
minimal and still had the sufficient
enough domestication traits
it's that speculative at best at the
moment but it seems
at least the intentionality may have
gone pretty far back now of course when
we're talking about baits and hybrids
and chickens and everything else it is
massively attentional and we're doing
genomic selection on these things but
when is that when did that
intentionality kick in is a really good
question but certainly it's also true
that the way that people were keeping
pigs for thousands of years after
domestic domestication was more of a
very free-range model and if you look at
things like donkeys and camels there are
no wild camels anymore but for a very
long time and donkeys even now will
readily interbreed with animals just
because they're kind of left to their
own devices and if they're left to do
their own thing then I'm sure a New
Guinea as well there's a relatively
common practice of putting pregnant sow
on a stick at the edge of the village
and waiting for the feral boar to come
in and mate with or overnight and then
you bring her and so there isn't a
degree of intentionality with that as
well as those series of different models
of ways to do that but then thinking
about how and how purposefully it's
being done is a bit of an open questions
kind of hard to read that strictly
through the archaeological record thanks
great
thanks for terrific presentation thank
you can you talk a bit about the
implications of in the reduction in the
genetic variety of for example swine and
intensified agriculture both for
thinking relative to Bill Murray's
comment particularly if they replace
after catastrophic events if you're
replacing with the same genetic stock as
prior to the event
yeah I mean most of my stuff tends to be
about eight to ten thousand years old so
my commenting on more modern breed
practices is so I can get on thinner ice
my understanding is where I'm working on
a lot of very large chicken project with
this and we just had someone come and
speak about the industrial chicken
production as well and there is
certainly an element a loss of genetic
heterogeneity of genetic variability
overall when you are going for single
traits that you're trying to maximize
but what's also true in all of the
domestic domestic animal industries is
that they're not just trying to maximize
a single trait and when you start to try
to maximize across several different
traits that significantly slows down
that process of how much homogenization
where then you start to get into a
situation where you have zero
variability and that are highly subject
to some sort of a virus that comes
through or an inability to process
particular feed or whatever it is so
it's there is certainly a reduction when
you are under a very strong selective
pressure to try and growth quick things
quickly to try and make the resistance
of various diseases and everything else
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's all do with gloom and that we're
all gonna be without to make pigs and
chickens whatever else in a matter of
years but it's certainly you know the
industry takes it seriously because they
know that if they don't we don't have
things anymore they're not making any
money anymore so but yeah it's the
incentives are not always aligned
perfectly between those
yeah one more question how could we tell
in terms of evidence whether the pig was
a commensal domesticate or not what
would we be looking for and why
since rats and pigeons and so on are
commensals but didn't become fully
domesticated is that human
intentionality that turned one commensal
into a domesticate and the other not
that's a good question it's seeing that
archaeologically is something I think
Ben might speak to a bit and there are
you can look at so the duration of how
long it takes what the changes are in
the bones what the change are in the
genetics over a very long period of time
and presumably if it's more of a
directed path way it's gonna be a much
shorter period of time than you would
see this over I have a slight issue with
this fully domesticated versus partially
domesticated there are populations of
rats that are very very domesticated
thank you very much they are existing in
labs and in four-year-old bedrooms all
over the nation all alongside their
hamsters in one corner or at the other
so there I think there is a variability
across the whole range and pigeon
fanciers there's no reason to think of
those as not domesticated there are
there are feral populations as well and
there are sort of things maybe in
between but there are certainly members
of a lot of different animals that would
qualify as a domestic animal based upon
any criteria so I think it's something
I've been in a little bit of a silly
I don't war is too strong a word but
please there's some people who claim the
cats are not fully domesticated I'm like
they sleep on your bed it may sleep on
your face in my way how is that not
anyway so yeah so I just Morgan issue
with the terminology of us drawing this
what criteria would you use to define
something that's fully domesticated half
domesticate what units are using like
number of hours spent on your face at
night is you know because cats are on
the pretty far extreme at that point so
but it is it's a really good question
okay great thanks
all right well good morning let's start
out by gave in the organizers for for
inviting me to dissipate in this in this
in this interesting assortment of
individuals talking about this is very
specific and yet broadly interesting
topic people keep like raising their
eyebrows when I tell them I was headed
up to to New Haven this weekend for a
conference I do know it's a pleasure to
be here so this morning I want to talk
about the origins of pig husbandry in
the Neolithic Neary's one of not the
earliest center of pig domestication in
the world I want to start briefly by
addressing the issue of domestication
very briefly since Gregor did a
wonderful job with that as we knew he
would I want to introduce the
archaeological evidence for animal
management and then turn to the
archaeological record of Neolithic
Southwest Asia where I do my work so
natural and cultural historians have
been addressing the origins of domestic
livestock for well over a century and as
a result there are many different
perspectives on what the term
domestication means for my purposes I
want to emphasize a few characteristics
of the domestication process which will
then attempt to follow in the
archaeological record first it's a
process of increasing interdependence
between humans and animals that's
characterized by great time depth so
it's a good thing for archaeologists to
address it results from significant
human impact on animal behavior
reproduction mobility and feeding it
involves intentional human use of
animals as opposed to commensalism and
it's the evolutionary process of
artificial selection usually
unconsciously applied which creates
biologically unique domesticates
domestication as gregor mentioned should
be seen as a relationship with animals
that is not isolated or unique but
rather sits on a continuum of more or
less intensive human animal
relationships all of which we may expect
to find in the archaeological record in
addition the boundaries of domestication
are often less than clear
differentiating between management of
wildlife and the manager
of domestic herds can be difficult as
the boundary between the two can be
difficult to assess as represented by
these farmed fallow deer taming reflects
an intimate relationship between human
and animal that can also be difficult to
distinguish from domestication
in addition domestication is not a
stable state with feral ization and as
we've just seen intro aggression between
wild and domestic animals a common
occurrence so turning to the
archaeological methods used to identify
the domestication process I want to
briefly introduce the four lines of
evidence that I'm going to follow first
it's expected that the abundance of a
taxon at an archaeological site or its
increase over time reflects an intensive
relationship that may develop into
domestication this is reflected here in
this figure showing a shift from
economies based on hunting gazelle
to herding sheep and goats in Neolithic
Israel second the expansion of an animal
outside of its natural range is often
assumed to be the result of intensive
human management and therefore
reflecting domestication as seen here by
the importation of large mammals to the
island of Cyprus however it's also clear
that humans have been dispersing both
wild and domestic taxa across the globe
for millennium so this line of evidence
is often quite difficult to assess third
domestic animals exhibit a suite of
biological changes known collectively as
the domestication syndrome these include
changes in horn-shaped coat color and
ear and tear molt tail morphology and
have been linked to intensive selection
for a reduced aggression required for
animals to live in close contact with
humans a process defined by the Soviet
geneticist Ameche belly-up as behavioral
selection one of the most important of
these changes for archaeologists is a
decrease in body size evident in most
domestic 'its and certainly in pigs
compared to their wild ancestors it is
important however to recognize that the
size is not a direct reflection of human
management since the earliest managed
animals likely maintained a wild
phenotype and domestic phenotypes can
sometimes be transferred into wild
populations through introgression
finally archaeologists also looking at
for herd management in the form of kill
off patterns to assess domestication
simply put human management generally
produces more juvenile animals in a
faunal assemblage whereas hunters tend
to target adult individuals so let's now
turn to the archaeological evidence from
Southwest Asia for the early management
of pigs and then we'll briefly touch on
the spread of pigs across the region and
beyond in the Paleolithic so fifty to
twenty thousand years ago mobile hunters
in the Near East
hunted a wide range of game including
wild boar but boar were not an important
part of early subsistence economies
representing only about 1% of the animal
remains at most sites however by the end
of the Pleistocene evidence from a
surprising place the island of Cyprus
tells us that they were major shifts
taking place in the humid of the human
suid relationship on Cyprus which was
never attached to the mainland
archaeological sites indicate that pigs
were transported to the island as early
as 10,000 BC well before the advent of
Agriculture here pigs represent the
primary prey species on the island and
were intensively exploited from about 10
to 8,000 BC jean-denis vena has argued
that these early Cypriot pigs are
significantly smaller than their
mainland counterparts but instead of
arguing for a pre Neolithic
domestication event he interprets this
as an example of Island dwarfism which
is a common process seen in the
ecological literature this is supported
by the very low frequency of juvenile
pigs
at these early sites which suggests that
boar were released to the island to be
hunted with the help of dogs so if an
increasingly intimate relationship with
boar was developing on Cyprus what was
happening back in the mainland at the
same time well at the site of gobekli
tepe in southeastern Turkey we have a
large settlement where hunter-gatherers
constructed impressive ritual structures
here pigs are only a small portion of
the economy and there is no evidence for
management although boar do play an
important role in the iconography of
this impressive site so they were
clearly an important
of the cultural landscape moving further
east we turn to the site of Holland
chemi pollen chemi is a very important
early village site contemporaneous with
the early sites on Cyprus and here
Richard Redding has made a very
well-known argument for the earliest pig
management anywhere in the world this
argument is based on the high frequency
of pigs at the site they're about 26% of
the of the final assemblage a relatively
high frequency of juvenile pigs and body
part profiles which suggests that entire
pig carcasses were brought to the
settlement although it's important to
note that this assemblage is currently
being reanalyzed and published by
Mindy's either the Smithsonian my take
on the evidence is a little bit
different from Redding's based on a
recent publication juvenile pigs are in
fact not very well represented at
Holland Jemmy especially compared to
later sites there is no evidence for any
morphological changes associated with
domestication and bor would have lived
very close to the settlement so it's
really no surprise that entire carcasses
would be present on site the
transportation costs would have been
very low so in short at the current time
there is really no good evidence at all
for pig management at Holland chemi
despite the fact that it usually shows
up in the literature as the as the
source of the earliest domestication of
pigs moving slightly to the west the
Neolithic site of China which Berger
mentioned as sort of one early sort of
genetic result it's probably the most
important place for documenting early
pig domestication the long occupational
sequence of the site provides a window
into the process of gradual
intensification in the human peek
relationship the people of China were
certainly pig lovers with pigs
representing half of the animal remains
of the site which is totally remarkable
for a Near Eastern economy in addition
morphological changes as well as kill
off patterns suggest that the first
successful experiments with pig
management were taking place here work
by Hitomi Hangzhou and Richard meadow
has shown that the China pigs exhibit a
gradual decrease in size over time which
begins in earnest in about the mid 9th
millennium BC in addition the length of
third molars
priests overtime reflecting shortening
of the snout characteristic of domestic
it's the frequency of enamel defects
markers of biological stress have been
shown to increase over time suggesting
increasing human control over diet and
mobility finally kill off data show an
increase in the frequency of juveniles
through time suggesting a gradual
increase in human the intensity of human
management over a 2,000 year
occupational sequence finally just one
more sight I want to move to the
Euphrates Basin to the site of the neva
love chewy which represents an early
Neolithic farming village culturally
similar to chinanu which yours Peters
has argued has the earliest evidence for
domestic sheep goat cattle and pigs
together in one place at neva Latorre
which is located in a rather dry
environment pigs represent only about
13% of the fawn on so it's quite
different from China however yours is
argued that the neva Latorre pigs
exhibit a decrease in body size compared
to boar from earlier sites in the region
consistent with a small domestic
population in addition carbon and
nitrogen isotope evidence has been used
to suggest human manipulation of the pig
diet possibly feeding animals
agricultural byproducts which represents
one of the earliest arguments for the
practice of intentional fodder II so to
summarize the evidence from the earliest
pig management in the Near East it's
clear that between about 12 and 8000 BC
an increasingly intimate relationship
was developing between humans and pigs
despite a generally low level of
interest in Seward's across the earliest
Neolithic Near East a few specific
communities developed what we might call
strong Pig cultures and it's from these
or perhaps just one of them that
domestic pigs first developed secondly
by the midnight millennium BC control
over the movement feeding and perhaps
breeding of some pigs resulted in the
appearance of primitive domestic
populations increasingly adapted to
living amongst humans so the
archaeological evidence is pretty clear
that southeastern Turkey was the
epicenter of the
earliest successful experiments with pig
management once domestic pigs are
present how quickly do they spread to
neighboring regions without traditions
of intensive boar hunting this is the
last question question I'd like to very
briefly address so with this graph I've
mapped out evidence for changes in body
size at 54 pigs from 50 Neolithic sites
in Turkey through time the colors
matched the regions on the map in the
corner what we see here is a pretty nice
picture of decrease in body size over
time associated with the long term
process of pig domestication you can see
that the decline in body size first
occurs in southeast Turkey the purple
dots where they we have good evidence
for early management then as Neolithic
communities spread west the orange
yellow and green dots domestic pig body
size continues to decline however
looking at the red data points
representing central Anatolian Neolithic
sites we see a different pattern in
which small sized domestic cats never
appear to put these data on a map we can
follow the spread of domestic pigs from
east to west across Turkey on their way
into Europe however the process is not a
smooth one pig management emerges very
early in the euphrates Basin but remains
isolated there for a long time
once it does emerge it moves quickly
westward along the coast of southern and
western Turkey here there's another
pause and it's a full millennium before
domestic pigs are brought into northwest
Turkey de strange was just you know an
inch or two on the map in addition in
the central Anatolian Neolithic domestic
pigs were never ever incorporated into
the economy despite the fact that for
three thousand years they were
surrounded by neighbors who were raising
pigs this suggests to me an intentional
long term really rather shocking
rejection of domestic pigs and pig
management and it turns out that this
pattern from the Turkish neolithic of
the lurching and patchy spread of
domestic pigs is repeated elsewhere in
the Near East it is the norm rather than
the exception to put this into sort of a
cartoony summary at about 9,000 bees
there is no sign of intensive Pig
management but we know that wild boar
are being captured and released to
Cyprus and this kind of relationship
might be happening elsewhere by the
midnight millennium we have the first
evidence of long-term pig management in
southeastern Turkey but it's only had
one settlement by 8,000 BC pig
management possibly including soldering
is still only present in the Euphrates
Basin in a few culturally related
settlements by the mid-80s pred
considerably within the Euphrates basin
and domestic pigs are being managed on
Cyprus possibly as a result of a
reintroduction of domestic animals
around 7,000 pig management finally
takes off and spreads with migrating
farmer hunt our farmer herders all the
way to Western Turkey and east to the
flanks to the Zagros Mountains at the
site of jarm oh by the mid seventh
millennium the footprint of pig
management hasn't changed much in large
areas of the Fertile Crescent including
most of Iraq most of Iran and the
southern LaVon are still without
domestic pigs it is in the early 6th
millennium no longer even the Neolithic
period we're in the next cultural period
the domestic pigs finally began to
appear in northwestern Turkey and the
southern Levant and by 5000 pig
management has been more widely
incorporated into these economies
however even in the fifth millennium
more than 3,500 years after the initial
domestication of pigs and by this time
pigs are already in Britain and
Scandinavia pig management has still not
spread into some of the major regions of
the Near East including central Turkey
and most of Iran so to conclude I want
to emphasize that we still know very
little about the earliest transition
from hunting to early pig management in
the Near East in the period before the
onset of the domestication syndrome
archeologists are really flying blind
without the evidence from Cyprus where
boar were clearly transported by people
in boats we wouldn't really have a sense
of the sophistication and intimacy of
hunters relationships with boar
populations we do however know that by
the midnight melon ium pig management
had progressed to the point that a few
populations start to show signs of the
domestication syndrome this is what we
usually point to is the
origins of pig domestication although
it's sort of an arbitrary point however
it's worth pointing out that the process
of domestication must have begun quite a
bit earlier than this and that the
biological processes associated with
domestication would continued through
the three millennia of the Neolithic
period and of course on to the present
day finally although the data from
Turkey and elsewhere in the near East
indicate that pig management appears
very early in the Neolithic it did not
spread very quickly and when it did it
was patchy in its uptake and seems to
have been emphatically rejected by many
communities this suggests that despite
the incredible potential of pigs as
sources of animal products there were
major technical environmental and
perhaps ideological problems that had to
be overcome in order to incorporate them
into Near Eastern economies and life
ways addressing these barriers to early
pig management has received almost no
archaeological attention and I think is
one of the really interesting ways are
our themes looking forward to address
that's really going to help us
understand the history of human suid
relationships
I love this picture by the way this is a
friend of mine thickness this is a boar
walking across the beach near Izmir in
western Turkey thanks I had a question
about the non uptake of pig management
in those two regions
I was wondering um because I work on
Britain and the British Empire in the
19th century and there but lots of
places where like certain animals are
not raised for a lot of the reasons you
suggested which include ideological
environmental cultural etc but also
because the economy is you know there
are regional specializations in
particular places and there's trading
that's going on between them so I was
wondering is it possible to tell if
that's part of what's happening in your
your keys are like how sophisticated are
these economies are people trading
specialized products back and forth and
does that have anything to do with the
basic answer is not really sure because
a lot of the animal products we just
don't see in their ecology
if they're like their skins if their
meat I think the general assumption is
if these prehistoric economies they're
pretty local they're pretty
self-sufficient there's not a lot of
evidence for that kind of
interdependence on our pumps or a
regional on a regional scale certainly
when you get a little bit later you get
sort of piece pieces together then
you're you're getting a much much more
kind of regionally integrated and
specialized economy it's an interesting
it's an interesting perspective because
really nobody in sort of this deep
prehistory than you know think is really
addressing that at all but but I think
probably probably there's not a lot of
reliance on the on the movement of basic
foodstuffs around for one reason you
know there's no evidence of
transportation is difficult right it's
all it's all human power it's all
there's some basic limitations with with
that and the general response of those
patterns is is for archaeologists who
again in prehistory tend to be
ecologically oriented is that it's an
environmental
the Near East is a it's largely a
seminary environment so that's probably
one of the strongest feature is
affecting where it makes sense to raise
water ET pigs but one of the things I
want to emphasize I think that's not so
I think the cultural component of choice
of other reasons this is much more
interesting I think probably much more
important than when you look at this
pattern it's just like why does it take
so long for demand meet domestic pigs
and say you know it's not that hard to
raise pigs and then the benefits are
pretty obvious but again to come back to
your question I think I think they're
mostly localized economies and it's it's
it's the internal logic of probably
different in each communities that why
they do were done thank you so much for
this really interesting presentation and
I would like to come back to this issue
ideological problems ideological
resistances to raising domestic pigs and
and I would like to do that by referring
to the chronological end point of your
story which you never never referred to
and justifiable reasons in your
presentation I'm curious about your way
of thinking why domesticated pigs
disappeared I mean it's the easy answer
is Islam I'm asking this as a historian
of Islam and Middle East and that sounds
to me you know I'm too easy of an answer
I really would like you to kind of you
know give us some clues about the ways
in which the reasons for the mr. guinea
pigs disappeared in Anatolia and and how
may that have affected local communities
or and the economies yeah yeah so that's
an interesting question yeah look at the
broader the broader patterns I mean pigs
are one of many species people have had
food choices right so there's a wide
range of options out there livestock to
hunt or not behind and what to eat and I
think when you look at it sort of very
broadly from sort of a general
one of anthropological perspective
there's a lot of sort of very very
coarsely like cultural filters being
used to decide you know what to what to
eat I think you know in Julius Caesar it
is in his writings on the on the garlic
where it talks about the Britons and how
they're kind of weird because they don't
eat hair and they don't and he lists a
couple of things that you know of things
that the ancient Britons didn't didn't
eat that that mainland Europeans did and
it's it's food choices it's often sort
of culturally oriented sometimes it has
an economic sometimes it has an
environmental component but a lot of
times I think you see that it has to do
with with with status and it has to do
with with identity and boundary
formation so when you talk about pigs in
later periods in the Near East
what you find what I find in Turkey in
my own work is it there is a you can
almost call it I would almost call it a
taboo against pork against pigs I mean I
think what I see in the data it is so
strong in prehistory the rejection of
pigs I mean they're the central Anatolia
is this this little you know plateau
there's literally surrounded by people
who are raising pigs and they absolutely
reject them for almost four thousand
years we actually don't know when the
first pig management is incorporated
back into that region but by the bronze
age by 2,000 BC it's a normal part of of
life things are like 10% of the economy
like they are throughout the near he's
kind of a supplemental meat source that
households can use for for again for
subsistence production but Bryan Hess
did some an Impala lawdness of his
archaeologists did some very interesting
work looking broadly at Israel Jordan
Lebanon the archaeological record in the
Iron Age for the origins of pig taboos
in the southern move on and what they
found was there are lots of places there
was lots of places including in Anatolia
in the Iron Age in the first a little
bit early in the second millennium where
pigs were were we're off the table or
either rejected or were or had a very
small percentage of the of the economy
so it's actually a fairly widespread
pattern of of strong cultural
associations with with pigs and you can
sort of underst i think thats related
partially to just two pigs themselves as
creatures right they're not like sheep
they're not like goats they're not like
cattle they're not you know eventually
like like chickens they're weird
they have different behaviors they have
different requirements they're often if
you look at you know Bronze Age texts
the early texts in the Middle East
they're often categorized as this sort
of strange other creature that's often
linked with dogs they're often
categorized with dogs as dirty animals
so they often have a negative sort of
ritual connotation like don't let the
pigs or dogs into the temple areas or
everything is messed up so there's
there's a really wide spread sort of in
some cases negative not something
necessarily all related but like
negative association with pigs that gets
picked up by specific communities in
different places I mean some some areas
in sort of early classical Anatolia are
known for pig production and others are
known for totally hating pigs and
keeping them outside of their their
settlements having strong urban rules
about keeping pigs away so I think it's
it frequently comes up it's a pretty
obvious mechanism that communities are
using for again for the reasons are
probably very much community and
chronologically specific you know for
for creating ethnic boundaries for
creating difference or for taking
advantage of an economic opportunity
or in some cases just too hard to manage
pigs but they suck up too much water and
then you know maybe they pollute the
water sources or create problems so
there's there's a whole bunch of
different answers that I think I think
it's just and it shows up again and
again partially just because of the
nature of pigs like the nature of their
of their difference from other other
livestock they're they're a good or good
target for sort of symbolic manipulation
if you have questions here and we'll
have some more time for Q&A after that
the next speaker thank you very much
and first of all I'd like to thank um
gator and older for inviting me along to
this conference and words pleasure to be
here it's very long way for me to come
away from Australia
27 hours bit tired but overall pretty
good um look greener and and and been
fully given up really interesting
stories on their perspectives I'm gonna
given different slightly different story
which sort of complements what they're
talking about I'm not actually going to
talk about domestication per se itself
I'm going to talk about a little bit
further along the line and the movements
of domestic Peaks into Ireland Southeast
Asia so I'm going to talk a little bit
first of all about the understanding we
have of the origins and roots of
translocation of mud through the modern
and genetic data peeks into Island
Southeast Asia I'm going to link that to
genetic evidence which Pig
translocations to zoo archaeological
record so we can so I can show you how
we get this time depth and we build up
this time depth for these translocations
that we see within that in the modern
DNA records and now I'm going to go to a
couple of case studies and look at me at
neolithic peaks in economies and new
modes of settlement so how pigs being
introduced to Ireland Southeast Asia or
may 99 in Southeast Asia and who's
introducing them and what for what
reasons shall we say and how are they
how are they embedded into those
economies and then in my final case
study I'm gonna look at a little bit I'm
gonna move to the Philippines from from
the mainland and we're going to look at
a little bit of social archaeology and
maybe some of the reasons beyond sort of
the obvious food resource economy
economic basis for introduction of pigs
towards more of a sort of social and
ideological perspective and how we
actually try and get at that in the
archaeological record so first of all as
I say domestic pigs pigs were
domesticated in China
eighteen thousand plus years ago and
they were moved from China central
central China Yara Galleria the Yangtze
River area they were moved through to
China down into southern China and then
into the northern fringes of what we
call Southeast age
yeah so if we look it's become my point
you're over Southeast Asia we're talking
about northern Vietnam here may 19th
East Asia Thailand Cambodia
here's island Southeast Asia here were
Borneo and Philippines Sumatra New
Guinea go through here into Melanesia
and then islands of Pacific so one of
one of the interesting sort of genetic
hammer types we've got is what we call
the Pacific plate or what Gregor and his
team called the Pacific plate here now
this is not a pig domestication here as
Gregor is said before in the earlier
talk what's probably happened is
domestic pigs being moved into northern
ireland and northern mainland southeast
asia and they've at least been admixture
and integration and they picked up this
this genetic marker here for the pacific
leg which is really very useful we can
then track that track that sorry track
that across mainland Southeast Asia
Island Southeast Asia and in the modern
genetics they were able to follow it
down through smarter Java and and
hypothesize a route out through into
around new inning into new guinea out
through the small Solomon Islands and
this play depicts is found all the way
out through to Hawaii okay right the
cross through the Pacific it was moved
over fast if different distances and we
know that also from the archaeological
record I'm going to stick with them
Maine and an island Southeast Asia story
mode the second interesting haplogroup
of the piece is what has put the land
new piece the land new land new is a
small island here between Taiwan and the
Philippines and we don't really still
don't know it's quite an admission truly
know the story of this this haplotype of
peak um but what we do know is this
distribution is just from Taiwan around
in the Philippines and it doesn't seem
to have been moved to anywhere else okay
but it probably originates maybe on
mainland and then again is picked up
this this signature somewhere in the
area where it's fine so that's a story
so we say with the modern modern story
now we can link that to the
archeological record so here I've got a
number of archaeological sites um where
we've actually found peeking remains
within the Neolithic period and we can
actually look at look at the early
introduction so we can then link the
genetics to the earlier introduction so
man back here domesticated Peaks we've
got from 3,700 cowardly people
there's no domesticated Peaks in
mainland Southeast Asia for for 4,500
big thing I they're all introduced after
that date then if we look at BAM non
walk in Thailand
we've got domesticated pigs they're at
3700 PP and we know that this is
specific trade signature there we go to
action and dr. yang and Rapa Nui in
southern Vietnam and I'm going to come
back to these these sites as one of my
case studies in the moment earliest
dates around 4000 we've also linked that
to the Pacific plate then if we go down
to Leon boar which is a cave site in
Flores we've got Pacific plate there
from around 3500 in my name is a paçoca
Massey Pacific plate they're from
possibly 3,500 BP and then out to what
Dom D which is a site in in the Moluccas
3200 beeping so we can trace it across
the island Southeast Asia from the
mainland across the island southeast
asian and that makes a nice link between
the modern genetics and the ancient
genetics and the archaeological record
so we have dates for these for these
translocations across and then it goes
out into the Pacific is found on Vanuatu
before 3,000 years ago and then out the
other clade there now new clave we've
got land new peaks at a place with
Salvador around 3200 and this is these
are islands for the pattarna sizes just
south of Lanyu and then next brand which
I'm going to talk about in my case study
here as well we've got a direct date on
pics out of four thousand four nine nine
four thousand three three two Calvi P
right and I'll come back to that a
little bit in a second so domestic pigs
settlements an economy so I'm going to
focus on some work I've been doing this
southern Vietnam and the sites of
they're here they're down in the Mekong
Delta region of southern Vietnam here
they're all quite close together about
80 kilometer park and shouldn't look to
yang about 300 meters apart so very
close together new East closer to the
coast
it was occupied slightly laters we were
seen seen in a minute and all these
sites are along major river river
channels and that's no coincidence and
as I'll come to as I go through here go
through through this part of the talk so
first of all I'm just going to touch on
a little bit on on ansion and logged
yang and then I'll talk a little bit
more extensively on on the site of Rapa
Nui so the earliest domestic peaks are
from from these two sites very close
together I had some dr. yang around
4,000 years ago these sites are they're
new to the region these sites appear
around about this this this time around
4,000 years ago they've got no
predecessors they just appear in the in
the environment along these River along
these major tributaries of the Mekong so
it suggests that people are actually
moving into the region
right and with them with them they're
coming their domestic pigs okay they've
also got dogs as well to see so we only
on these early early sites we identified
two recently identified these domestic
animals by age profiling so this is this
mandible here I'm showing here is a
young people we know it's a young pig
because it's still got some of the
deciduous teeth in it so we can identify
as Ben was mentioning we can identify
this as young pits peaks that there's a
majority of young pigs in the assemblage
and we can say with a degree of
confidence that these are likely to be
domestic phase managed pigs in the past
like that the present peak management
you you you'll find it you don't need to
keep pigs very long unless you're going
to breed with them you slaughter them at
a young age there's no point keeping
them to adulthood I and this you're
gonna keep them for breeding then we got
the a DNA on it
the a DNA Pacific plate that supports
our understanding that they're they're
domestic pigs the settlement Iraq Nui
slightly later as we see it dates to
around 3500 it's a Meritage site and
these these sites go up to about five
meters deep there's me stood in the
bottom of the hole there
when we've just finished excavating this
trench so here's that here's the mayor
isn't what's left the main itself like a
lot of these sites in Vietnam they build
walking great thing for gonna on it
because it stands out and they like to
stick their pagodas on things that stand
out in the landscape there's common
religious protest and then we've got
some previous excavation treaties we dug
trench one here eight meters by 4 meters
trench to which the two trenches I shall
talk about mostly then we got trench
three here and we dug a little to the 12
trench over the side here we wanted to
investigate the nature of the
archaeological record here to understand
the development of the site the
settlement patterns how that home how it
was constructed the economy of these
people that had actually moved into this
site so this five meters of deposit and
we found over 13 phases of reconstruct
reconstructed so we say structures on
the site and what the image here shows
is one of the earlier structures this is
one of the drawing of of this you can
just see that from the photograph the
outlines you see this find out lies here
these are actually these these sort of
fence lines this areas raced slightly in
the middle like a small platform and
then there's total fences around the
outside inside you can see the light
color here this is actually remnant
surfaces has been deliberately laid and
our hypothesis at the moment is that
they're using show line water so they're
producing show line water they're
producing these floors on these on these
slightly raised platforms and then
they're constructing their the buildings
are structured on that when we had first
excavate this site five meters deep we
thought well they must have been doing
this for a very very long time building
all these structures and when we got the
dates back to our astonishment all five
meters had gone up in less than 300
years so they've been reconstructing
reconstructing a quite a rapid rate so
if we look at the pro if we look at it
in profile this is what I'm talking
about so the one of the floor surface I
was showing you just now is one of these
phase 1 phase 2's but you see phase 3 4
4 5 6 so what they're doing is they're
building that then
in their structures houses then they're
knocking the whole thing down and
they're rebuilding on top again and it's
going up and up now all right so they're
slowly raising a great surface and you
can see even these big post holes he's a
big supporting post they're rebuilding
them over and over again they're doing
exactly the same thing time and time
again and I reached reconstructing the
bode this whole long as I say 300 years
which was quite astonishing so they're
read they must be knocking these
structures down and rebuilding the
memory 10 to 15 years so not only do we
have these structures these little
raised platform structures that I was
talking about in trench one which is
this one here in trench to the L shape
on the end here we also have these nice
rectangular little structures here this
is in the process of being excavated
these are all aligned with the other
platforms so that there's this
settlement for this is actually telling
us is this settlements actually planned
is laid out though it's designed from
the affluent from it from its inception
the people who built these settlements
knew what they were actually doing when
they finally starting to build these
platforms and first place because of the
amount of investment being being put
into actually construction of these of
this settlement it's likely to be
permanent or at least semi-permanent you
don't bother them to make show lime
water floors if you're going to leave
next week all right so they're actually
staying that they're there on a on a
fairly permanent basis nobody's lived in
this area before it does sea level had
dropped pretty recently and they moved
into this area so really these are
pioneer settlers they're moving into
Darien they're coming in what are they
actually doing economically this is we
do archaeologists do for a living we set
ourselves out we look at all the animal
bones we identify all the animal bones
and we actually try and identify how
many how much of each species we've got
don't worry about minimum numbers of
individuals and a nice piece that's what
we zoologist do
we're on what's important is you look at
the pink stone here domestic piece
there's quite a lot of domestic pigs but
if you look at what else is there and in
terms of mouths mouths reptiles and
birds you can see there's lots of
reptiles
lots of turtles people like to eat
turtles people like to eat monitor
lizards and even the result water
crocodiles there's a lot of so crocodile
bones and a lot from the butchered and
they're certainly eating those probably
taking the skins whatever monkeys we're
over all these only sites we get monkeys
domestic dogs is quite a lot of domestic
dogs here so they're introducing dogs
and pigs are coming with them and the
dogs are just also butchered every
single site I look on in the nearly
thing across Ireland South East Asia and
mainland Southeast Asia there's got lots
of butchered dog bones and so pigs are
actually integrated into what you can
see here into into a quite a diverse
economy and there's lots of other
different taxa being introduced as well
so if we look at this overall we've got
this new settlement pioneer settlement
these people are coming in they're
building their settlement right and then
and then they're actually bringing pigs
and pigs and dogs with them we also know
they've got rice with them but not very
much and also my my botanical people the
big botanical people that work with us
at the saying that this rice looks like
they can tell from the types of
materials that are actually finding they
can tell that that rice that's coming in
is actually being brought in rather than
being grown locally and this is this is
still a stirring there it's very salient
wouldn't be good for right so the rice
is coming in so they've they've got the
domestic got the domestic pigs but as
you can see there's a huge reliance on
other resources particularly aquatic
resources hundreds of thousands of fish
bones so they're catching an awful lot
of fish they lose in a lot of different
trapping techniques so that the domestic
animals are not really them at this
stage maybe not really the major
economic factor within within there
within their resources this might well
be because at this stage these are
pioneer people they're moving in to
these new areas and they're still
extremely heavy reliant on other
resources particularly until they get
established all right so this is really
really interesting we're seeing the
early stages of these people these these
new sort of agriculturalists are moving
into the region bringing with
these resources with them now I'm going
to move beyond film from that onto onto
the second case study and peaks in the
social context I'm going to move from
Vietnam into into the Philippines now
Gabe was on about yesterday was on about
it's sort of swine ology and I've got a
swine ology fact here today for us the
Philippine Archipelago I don't know if
you know actually has more species of
hay than anywhere else in the world
that's this species to smoker or your
age and world war the Philippines
actually has six species of pig in the
North up here we thought sisters
Filipino disease in the central region
is just sever fronds here in men dog
Mindoro is liver right here in Palau one
Zeus a homeowner barbers and then down
here in the South Nia is just Barbados
and right across the entire island is
they introduced domestic pig sus scrofa
amazing there we go
a swine ology fact for us this morning
now to get back to what I've blown my
story I'm talking about the psychic or
next bra it's up here again it's along
one of these major major river channels
all these Neolithic sites at this date
are along these major river river
channels primarily it's shell midden and
it's a big show this is all she'll meet
is a shell and people are living on top
of these shows are building their houses
on top of these shows this is a human
burial in the bottom here as well so
this is an excavation this pot pot I'm
talking about his excavation took place
in 2009 show me the showman itself it's
a little bit later it dates from about
2500 to 1600 BP but the early phases are
underneath and underneath his burial
yeah and that dates from about 4,000
3,000 BP
along with the showman heat shell
middens thinner here towards the other
side
lots of post holes so they're
constructing they're constructing their
settlements on there on this site and
within the showman and within the clay
layers underneath the layer myth
Neolithic layers we get lots of animal
bone this is a big pig mandible and
we've got lots of animal bones mixed in
with the shell
hypothesis here is that they're actually
constructing their houses above grain
level
stilted it's very common in the
Philippines to do this and they're
chucking the bones over the edge off off
the structures are getting incorporated
into the into the shell and that's why
you get this really nice well-deserved
and peak Vanderbilt animal bone and lots
of dog gnawing we also got dog burials
as well so they've got dogs dogs there
as well as pigs yeah and basically if we
look at the fauna here we've got we've
got some fish we've got some deer
introduced Buffalo a little bit later on
and pigs dominate dominate a lot but if
we then look at the pigs themselves okay
we've got two different species we've
got the endemic wall picket and we've
got introduced domestic peace and in
this case it's really quite easy to tell
the difference between the Philippine
wild boar yeah these are really
diminutive they're small pigs and this
is an introduced domestic piece so this
peak this toothy and these are both the
same teeth the upper third molar this is
the endemic World War
this is domestic pig here because it's
quite straightforward to identity
differentiate between them we can look
at how many of each of these species are
actually in the archaeological record so
if we if we do that we can measure so
these are straightforward bimodal plots
looking at length versus width and then
we've got modernist modern specimens
specimens and subscribe for a circular
and modern specimens assists Philippine
ancestors squares and then all the
crosses are actually the archaeological
specimens and you can see they divide up
very nicely very nicely indeed so we can
identify the endemic world or from the
introduced domestic source profile so
what does this allow this do well one we
can be very confident that the peak
tooth that we dated a domestic pig
because we can separate it from the
world things very easily what we can
also do is look at the wild pigs and
domestic peace in terms of numbers what
are we actually seeing in terms of are
there more wild pigs or more domestic
things but one when we look at it as you
can see especially in this graph here
you see there's a lot
Wolpe than there is domestic pee in fact
we have a ratio of wild picked domestic
pick to four to one okay that's
interesting this seems to suggest that
there actually there are tea hunting
more well pink than they are more
whopping again are being introduced
through from fruit resource authorities
rather than the domestic piece so what
does this actually mean
well where's Evan a graphic parallels to
this the if ago in northern luzon they
keep native black pigs specific
specifically for ceremonial and ritual
purposes and they differentiate these
from general eating pace and and I
suspect that the possibility is that
we're also seeing this in the past figs
are not only just being introduced in
the economic resource but this there's
something else going on there there's
there's something in terms of the way
they look at these new resources that
they're bringing in or they've been
brought in and the way they're actually
using and utilizing those who live these
resources so I've done a quick sort of
Whistlestop tour shows so to speak of
the archaeology in Southeast Asia but
I've tried to pick out some points one
one how we actually follow domestication
how we how we've been able to see how
animals have been translocated across
I've looked at sort of human settlement
settlement patterns you know that the
resources the the importance of domestic
peaks within these very early economies
and then I've tried to look at a little
bit more about the sort of social
archaeology and how and why pigs beyond
the economic function why they may well
have also been introduced to places like
Ireland Southeast Asia
thank you I think we have time for maybe
one question for dr. pepper and maybe in
the process the rest of the panelist
could come up so that we can have
questions the whole panel
I have a question that's sort of
inspired by Philips comments and but
really for the whole panel and that is
uh I'll let me be preface which is that
I only pretend I work on pigs but I'm
really in Afghanistan and not that they
don't have things in Africa without
domesticated didn't raise them to the
same extent and in one say in the late
1960s as an anthropologist named Claude
- who came up with the totally speculoos
theory that cattle domestication was
primarily facilitated and intended for
the purpose of promoting bribery well
and as I said totally speculoos not
based on any archaeological evidence but
there's pretty good evidence a pretty
good ethnic graphic evidence that cattle
don't form much of an economic resource
in terms of food cans in terms of
consumption pastoralists tend not to eat
beef except an extremely rare occasions
and once you get past this mix
pastoralism in agriculture that you
don't even get much dairy consumption
except in for for elites so but
nonetheless cattle are vital to to
social economies in all sorts of ways
and so that leads me to the question
that's I think Bank by Philips example
in the end which is which is what our
pigs for and I think it also goes to in
Ben's presentation there's an assumption
I think that we all make which is that
when communities refused to domesticate
pigs then we looked for ideological
meanings to those to that refusal but we
don't ask the same question when they do
the investigative team deserts are just
as self-evident practical purpose but
the evidence presented suggested for
example that pigs were imported into
Cyprus for purposes that were not I mean
there was a great effort made to bring
pigs with you but not consume them for
me so there but clearly they were useful
in some way there was a there was some
point to having them there and also the
the sort of the nature of the monumental
architecture not monumental
original features at you that you found
all across Western Anatolia
just as well that that there's an
audiological rich purpose in in in pigs
that certainly goes is it's not limited
to a reducible to just the fact that
they're that they're kind of tasty so so
what I want to know about is a social
organization and what can we say about
the forms of social or just as and in
the African africanist example that when
you think about bridewealth and clan
ship and and in forms of lineal descent
and the ways that that produces
patriarchy the way so that produces plan
in clan relationships in transaction
what kinds of social organization can we
talk about in these in this sort of
swath of Asia that would facilitate a
promote the relationships with pigs
either either refusing to have them or
end or promoting their access to access
to pigs
so that's my question yeah sure that's a
whopper right I I really like the way
you are sort of flipping the
conversation to talk about why pigs
what's the what's the function because
you're absolutely right
archaeologists certainly assume right
from hindsight like from our world where
you know most of us are agriculturalists
to rely on livestock it's like how how
could you live without this it's as an
obvious subsistence economy sort of
focus that is 100% the perspective the
biased perspective that we take back to
10,000 BC to the archaeological record
and it's created a narrative in which
you're trying to explain the obvious
like it's the the obvious logical choice
we always sort of think of
hunter-gatherers these pitiful starving
people who you know haven't figured out
the great idea Gregor you you you
mentioned the idea that it's it's in
critique the fact that it's it's often
seen as a intentional process of this
sort of genius prehistoric person was
like I'm going to take that dog or that
or ox or that boar and turn it into this
economically wonderful thing which is
obviously total
nonsense and its of just we're
projecting ourselves back but that's
that's what you see in the literature
it's it's and it's kind of it's you know
based in sort of cultural ecology it's
based in some you know ecological models
of increasing forager efficiency if you
if you control and manage your resources
but but I I think the most interesting
question to ask these days is sort of
why are you domesticating and if you
look at the evidence I think it's not
for food I think you're absolutely right
I think the African example with with
cattle is probably sort of the best and
sort of biggest example of an entire
sort of way of life focused on an animal
and it's not about eating the animal
it's about the social uses of animals
and so I think that that perspective
needs to be projected back to the past
and and I think you can probably it's
hard to like pipe on it's hard to create
a testable hypothesis about that but I
think I think you can so you can come up
with something to do that
the wheels are turning there but but I
think the domestication of animals is
totally about manipulating human social
relationships it's not about getting
enough calories I mean these
hunter-gatherers they could get enough
calories I mean these are these are
genius ecologists I mean they know how
to get enough food and when you look at
the archaeological record
I think there's absolutely no evidence
for for any shortage in in in game like
this is the usual argument domestication
happened because hunters settled down
and they ate all the food and so they
had to manage their resources if you
look in the southern LaVon in Israel in
the Jordan Valley that sort of looks
like it works but elsewhere Iran Turkey
Lebanon everywhere else it's nonsense
there's no support for that at all so
it's it's social reasons it's social
reasons that people are are keeping
these animals ready and I think the
phils example of the sort of ritual use
of certain pigs for certain particular
purposes is exactly right that's what's
happening there are really strong
cultural associations with these animals
I mean hunting hunting societies have I
mean you know often these animals are or
are persons right they're non-human
persons that are connected to a much
totally complicated
you know connected worldview and so what
does it mean that you're bringing a
non-human person right perhaps into your
into your community why do you have it
there why do you need to have it handy
for a purpose and so I think that the
mean we try to find a Sorak yellow just
working in prehistory who it actually
really hard to get those stories
published because when I try to talk
about that the science oriented sort of
ecologically oriented archaeologists are
like this is nonsense like where's the
you know where's the where's the model
testing where's the optimal foraging
theory application so it's hard to
figure out at least for me how to how to
address the question of how do you clip
social organization into the story of
domestication and you can use some
analogy right I mean so that's that's
sort of what we're we're left with but I
mean but I mean just the broad answer I
think is that that's exactly the
reasoning that the trick is looking back
to prehistory and trying to to figure
out the mechanisms that that brought
people and animals together but I don't
think it was for food it was for just
just those bridewealth know just to
follow up on that I think you're
absolutely right and I the interesting
room for me is very much like going what
Ben was saying about how we tend to
project our current scenario onto the
past and then say well how do we get
there and one thing that I was trying to
emphasize in my talk was that this sort
of accidental nature of history that you
there is it's all short termism
it's all using something for a specific
purpose and then there's an axe there's
a byproduct that then gets the attention
and when that byproduct gets the
attention the origins of it in
retrospect to get really confused and it
was a really great example with glass so
you know Bill Bryson's got this great
quote about how you could stand him on
the edge of a beach and you know it
would take them forever to look at it
say oh I mix the sand a little bit of
potash I could invent Windows you just
you don't because in retrospect you
can't possibly see how that would work
and when you look at the origins of
glass what happens is that people are
doing making glazes and the the process
of making a glaze releases at least kind
of like shiny little bits that are an
accidental byproduct of that process and
then when you start focusing then all of
your efforts on the byproduct you can
then say wow that's kind of shiny an
interesting but it wasn't accidentally
kind of flame off of making the glaze
and then you start creating the glass
and so it's in the same way that people
early domesticate animals and this is
exactly what Ben was saying when you
look at the chickens nobody's eating
chickens for thousands of years people
have chickens but there's no
archaeological evidence that they're
being eaten there's cockfighting well
before you've got evidence for eating
chickens you've got ritual practices
with chickens for a very long period in
specific pots as part of funerary things
but it makes no sense to eat a chicken
on a large scale because there's so
little meat on the bones we think of a
chickens now chickens are like five
times bigger now than they were 10 20
years ago
so you even you know a thousand years
ago God from it would just take way too
much effort to try get a meat off a
chicken bone it just makes no sense and
you have chickens in the early iron age
in the UK but for a very long time all
the way up through the Romans nobody's
eating them and that's very clear and I
think that as we start shifting that
focus around rather than saying well we
eat them now so he must have eaten them
then I can't think of a single animal
actually that the early archaeological
evidence suggests that they are being
consumed in the way that we think of it
now and so if you start as the eating is
only the accidental byproduct of
focusing on like we do with glass with
the fianc when you're making the glazes
early domestic animals it's not about
food it's about lots and lots of other
things and it's this whole kind of
ritual element and religious element and
as and when you look at gobekli tepe
it's amazing like the way in which
they're building these giant monuments
these are hunter-gatherers on the plains
still taking enough time to do us I mean
they had plenty of time I don't mean to
imply they didn't but just being able to
organize to get these massive stones
together and put all these different
animals from boar to snakes to cattle to
all kinds of stuff on there so animals
are being integrated into human
societies in a way that has nothing
whatsoever to do with production for
food and that's only a much later thing
and when we make a really big mistake
when we then apply that on to the past
that's like it's a really great point
yeah I was just tronic judged showed the
example for exactly exactly that reason
and as Ben says it's very hard for
archaeologists to get this and and and
even harder first publishes this sort of
certainly sort of a sort of idle
ideological social social perspectives
behind sort of the use of domesticated
animals so the chicken is a really good
example in in Southeast Asia in Ireland
Southeast Asia particularly where
cockfighting is absolutely huge and its
dog use in the Philippines they've got
an entire TV channel dedicated to
cockfighting I'm
it's just massive so what came first the
chicken the [ __ ] for cockfighting or
chickens to eat well I think I would
agree with Gregor there's a blazer
there's a it seems to me that
cockfighting is probably it's been there
a very very long time and and that could
well have been the reason why also we
see do the Mystics a domesticated
chickens are quite rare in the
archaeological record and that again
could be quite certainly the Neolithic
archaeological record and that could
also be one of the reasons why they're
quite rare is because they're not I'd
see an economic resource in the early
days at all being used for other other
reasons such as such as as called for
you and also we all remember that we've
been talking about domestication here in
terms of in terms of animal human animal
interactions and that domestication and
the agricultural process as a whole and
that shift to sedentary lifestyles to
managing animals that was a huge human
psychological shift and you will see all
kinds of weird things going on and I
think Ben might be able to clarify a bit
more and and in in that region they're
like chattel hoyuk and you start to get
all these sort of weird statues of
animals and all kinds of things and it's
all to do with this sort of people that
people are behaving in the environment
very differently to what they've done
throughout prehistory before that time
and it's and that's psychological shift
is clearly there's a conflict going on
in their minds and they're trying to I'm
trying to accept it to a certain extent
about how they how they manipulate I
started manipulating the environment in
a way that they've never done before and
and and that's part of the part part of
this processes are also with with the
wood the way that they're having their
relationships with with animals and how
those relationships are changing do one
more question than I think this is a
question for Philip the as if I'm not
mistaken around 5,000 BC you have a
migration of Austronesian populations
from Taiwan to Southeast Asia it would
astound me if they didn't bring their
pigs with them and
according to some kind of theories they
found the they were I gather a
cultivating people beforehand and when
they got to Southeast Asia they found
the environment so rich that they
basically gave up cultivation and became
foragers hunters and so on and so why
what prevented why did if they didn't
bring their things why not if they did
bring their pigs why didn't they then
mix with the pigs of the Pacific or
whatever is it a quite ugly given that
migration why don't we have a mixture of
the different things
I'm I'll start here in the ingredient I
in this in this presentation today I
deliberately avoided going into the
whole Austronesian speaking people's
migration across island Southeast Asia
because that's a big story in its own
right and I could have taken up my whole
talk talk with that so I kept very much
with thee what we know about that the
translocation domesticated animals
across into into island Southeast Asia
from mainland Southeast Asia
specifically with the pigs
there's the stood the stories ongoing
here and it's and it's interesting
because they didn't take the pigs from
from the Philippines across at all and
that's very clear this new human
genetics come out from Vanuatu now and
the archaeological records
seems to be fairly clear that there was
the Philippines where people came from
to go out through how to go to Polynesia
they do have their they do seem to have
their origins from that that region of
island Southeast Asia but um the
movement domestic animal seems to have
been extremely complex all across across
the region and pigs were not one one of
the things that actually went with those
individuals from the Philippines do you
want to yeah I think that's it that
belies the same kind of thing we were
just talking about where we
take in the present we then take that
thing and put it in the past and use of
this word package all the time I mean
Ben's been you know cutting our teeth in
the in the field it's all the Neolithic
package of the Austronesian package and
it consists of a certain number of
animals and plants and cultural
Potteries whatever else and that's when
we see that come together as a whole we
then assumed it was moving as a single
unit from a point of source then we just
try and track it all the way through but
in the same way that we can't imagine
that people who had first domestic
animals were necessarily eating them
that wasn't the purpose necessarily in
exactly the same way these packages
didn't exist either
and the evidence certainly from anatolia
is that the way in which these different
animals we think of MU even I make the
same mistake all the time we throw cows
sheep goat and pigs all into the same
economic unit and call that that's
what's happening in Anatolia but really
when you start getting to the
nitty-gritty of it you realize that the
cows the pigs and the sheep they're all
slightly different and they all are
coming together in different ways and in
different places and for the
Austronesian perspective it's really
certainly looks like the dogs the pigs
the chickens the pottery the rice
everything's got its own individual
story and you only recognize it after
it's come together by the time it gets
passed as the fine line between near and
remote Oceania at which point we
recognise it as a thing and then try and
track it all the way back before that
and that's absolutely not the case but
it's really interesting and this is the
paper that Phil and I are working on
together right now is that the there is
this land new Pig that's clearly being
traded or moved back and forth between
Taiwan the bataknese and at least
northern Philippines possibly down a
little bit further south but the pig
that's in the Pacific has nothing
whatsoever to do with that and that's
coming through a completely separate
trajectory now what the people are doing
is whether they're coming from different
sources in the Malka mating and AD
mixing in different ways and then you
finally end up with a position where
you've got a pig from over here a
chicken from over here which may have
come across a completely differently
you've got some really cool evidence
about that and so once we start breaking
the package up into its individual units
the story gets a hell of a lot more
complex a lot more interesting and a how
about more satisfying because that's the
way the life works it's not just like
these monolithic things that are just
happening through space and time so for
example in southern Vietnam
I've got they've got they've got pigs
and dogs but as far as I can tell at the
moment there's no cattle whereas in
Thailand that same sort of period of
time they've got cattle and in the
neolithic there so there's different
trajectories coming and there
these animals are coming in from as
Gregor says from different places that
there is no package so to space I think
in the interest of time will and the
interest of replenishing our caffeine
levels will know please join me in
thanking us for a great start to our day
of psychology